Buonasera a tutti, sono un ricercatore del Consiglio Nazionale delle Ricerche,
e lavoro in un istituto di scienze e tecnologie dei materiali ceramici compositi
che ha sede a Faenza. Sono venuta qui con il mio - cranio vi prometto che
non vi reciterò l’Amleto di Shakespeare - ma vi parlerò di materiali per la medicina
rigenerativa, attività che svolgo con un gruppo di giovani molto motivati che fanno parte del mio gruppo che vedete qui elencati.
La medicina rigenerativa lavora, ha un forte impatto su molte delle chirurgie,
in particolare la chirurgia ortopedica, la neurochirurgia,
la chirurgia maxillo-facciale e dentale. E’ ormai sotto gli occhi di tutti
che lo stile di vita e l’invecchiamento della nostra società hanno creato
un impatto molto negativo sulle patologie che riguardano l’apparato
muscolo-scheletrico; in particolare le cause possono essere di carattere traumatico
o degenerativo, come le infezioni croniche, le malattie tumorali.
In tutti questi casi, il chirurgo, in sala operatoria, si trova a far fronte
alla mancanza di tessuto, sia che egli asporti una porzione sia per ragioni
degenerative sia per ragioni traumatiche. Ora il tessuto osseo è uno dei pochissimi
tessuti del nostro organismo che è sì in grado di riparare una frattura
ma non è in grado di rigenerare ampie porzioni di se stesso, porzioni massive,
pertanto il chirurgo si trova davanti all’impossibilità di far fronte a questa
mancanza di tessuto, se non attraverso l’utilizzo di impianti ossei,
cioè intelaiature tridimensionali che noi dobbiamo progettare in modo tale
che le cellule lo riconoscano, aderiscono a questo impianto, vi prolifichino
e rigenerino pian piano il tessuto mancante, sia digerendo l’impianto e rigenerandolo,
o anche lasciando in sito, ma il nostro target è quello di far scomparire
completamente l’impianto osseo, e quindi di creare un ponte nuovo,
dove era lo spazio del tessuto mancante, formato esattamente identico
allo stesso tessuto osseo mancante.
Le problematiche più frequenti, come abbiamo detto, sono relative alle ossa lunghe
per ragioni traumatiche - pensate al numero enorme di incidenti
sono dovute a deformità dello scheletro, sono problematiche relative alle ossa piatte,
è il caso delle ossa del cranio.
Oggi non so se siete tutti a conoscenza del fatto che per qualunque trauma cranico
di una entità sopra il valore medio, quindi medio-alta,
il chirurgo asporta l'opercolo cranico e si aspetta un certo tempo
che è necessario per la decompressione dell’ematoma dei centri nervosi quindi,
non si fa più come una volta, in cui paziente veniva tenuto e si aspettava
che cosa succedeva e a che cosa avrebbe portato quel trauma.
Oggi si apre il cranio e si aspetta la decompressione per evitare lesione
dei centri nervosi. Poi questo cranio deve venire richiuso,
ma il nostro osso asportato non è più in grado di chiudere la cavità aperta
perché va  incontro ad un processo di riassorbimento rapido,
per cui il nostro opercolo cadrebbe  all'interno, per cui deve essere progettato
un materiale. Allo stesso modo, tutte le problematiche osso-cartilagine
dovute alle lesioni dell’articolazione del ginocchio, dell'anca,
rappresentano una patologia estremamente frequente negli sportivi,
e anche in tutta la popolazione in una fascia di età molto ancora bassa,
in individui molto giovani. Tradizionalmente si interveniva,
per ovviare a tutte queste problematiche, cercando di risolvere il problema
dal punto di vista funzionale; quindi sono state progettate delle soluzioni,
come vedete qui descritte, placche metalliche, viti, grandi protesi metalliche,
nel periodo che va dagli anni ‘60 fino all’inizio degli anni ‘90
tutta la progettazione delle protesi e degli impianti è dominata dalla ricerca
sulle plastiche, sui materiali metallici, si pensava a riprodurre,
a ripristinare la funzionalità del paziente; non ci si preoccupava di quanto
queste protesi o queste placche metalliche che tipo di impatto avrebbero avuto
sull’organismo, cioè un impatto estremamente invasivo: voi immaginate
che per introdurre una protesi di questo tipo, il chirurgo deve asportare
una porzione molto estesa del tessuto osseo, oltre a quello già mancante.
Quindi, poiché la durata delle protesi è di un tempo limitato,
non va oltre i 10-15 anni, se viene protesizzato un individuo giovane,
la protesi poi dovrà essere sostituita e il chirurgo si troverà davanti a un problema
doppio di quello iniziale.
Oggi il ricercatore che si occupa di sviluppo di materiali nella medicina rigenerativa
ha pensato di prendere ispirazione dalla natura: ci sono vari modi con cui possiamo
prendere ispirazione dalla natura, in quanto la natura è un progettista abilissimo,
ha fornito materiali estremamente performanti, materiali multifunzionali,
capaci di autorigenerarsi; e quindi noi possiamo seguire un approccio top-down,
e prendere questi materiali dalla natura, come la natura ce li fornisce,
e trasformarli a nostro piacimento; oppure possiamo copiare dalla natura come,
appunto, ingegnere abilissimo, e copiare i processi che la natura mette in atto
per produrre i suoi materiali. Un esempio di approccio top-down è quello
che abbiamo realizzato nei nostri laboratori: dopo una estensiva ricerca sulle specie
arboree, abbiamo identificato un materiale che si chiama Rattan,
è un legno che viene utilizzato per fare sedie da giardino.
Potete vedere da questa immagine l’incredibile similitudine del Rattan
con il tessuto osseo umano, dove noi riconosciamo questi canali centrali,
che sono al centro dell’osteone, questi canali haversiani attraverso cui passano
i vasi sanguigni, una serie di strutture porose intorno al canale haversiano
che consente ai fluidi e all’ossigeno di portare, diciamo, nutrimento alle cellule,
una struttura lamellare complessa che dà le proprietà meccaniche e funzionali al
tessuto osseo; e tutte queste caratteristiche di struttura gerarchicamente organizzata,
dalla nano alla macroscala, tipiche del tessuto osseo, le abbiamo ritrovate nel
Rattan, questo legno. Abbiamo quindi pensato di mettere a punto un processo,
cioè di prenderlo dalla natura e di trasformarlo. Il processo di trasformazione
è un processo chimico multi-step che parte da una pirolisi, che come fosse un processo
di fossilizzazione, come quando si trova un tronco antico di milioni di anni
che ha questa caratteristica di essere stato trasformato in carbone,
perché viene trovato sotto il terreno, allo stesso modo noi abbiamo attuato
questo processo che parte da un processo di pirolisi, e otteniamo quindi la
trasformazione della cellulosa in un templante, in una struttura a base di carbonio,
e cambiamo, senza mai modificare la struttura del Rattan, cambiamo la chimica
intorno a questo atomo di carbonio, introduciamo il calcio, elemento fondamentale,
l’ossigeno, il carbonato, il fosfato.
Alla fine abbiamo ottenuto lo stesso Rattan, stessa struttura tridimensionale
gerarchicamente organizzata con la composizione chimica dell’idrossiapatite,
la fase minerale, costituente l'80% in peso del tessuto osseo umano.
Adesso vediamo un filmato che ci mostra come l’osso abbia questa struttura
tridimensionale, gerarchicamente organizzata, molto difficile da riprodurre in
laboratorio, ma facile da trovare in natura, e quindi, avendo la struttura
– vedete riprodotta in questo Rattan – , noi possiamo trattarla chimicamente,
senza alterare la morfologia e la struttura complessa del Rattan.
Vengono utilizzati dei forni in alta pressione e quello che otteniamo alla fine,
appunto dopo questo trattamento, è un templante, cioè una struttura in carbonio
che mantiene la forma; quell’atomo di carbonio viene poi trasformato in idrossiapatite.
Questi materiali sono già stati sperimentati sugli animali – gli ultimi animali sono,
in questo momento in sperimentazione agli ospedali ortopedici Rizzoli di Bologna
e sono stati impiantati in un difetto critico di una pecora; cosa vuol dire critico?
cioè questo materiale è stato progettato per far fronte alla problematica di mancanza
di segmenti lunghi per la sostituzione di ossa lunghe portanti carico,
che hanno quindi una struttura per cui la biomeccanica dell’osso verrà rispettata
durante il processo di rigenerazione ossea.
Quindi, la vedete, il controllo radiografico è stato ottimo e l’istologia,
che vedete riportata qui, fa vedere che il materiale è stato completamente
rigenerato da tessuto osseo nuovo. Pensate quindi all’impatto, quando questo materiale
entrerà nei test clinici – subito dopo la fine dei test animali passerà alla clinica –
l’impatto che potrà avere un materiale di questo genere, che vedete inserito in un
femore della donna che sta correndo, rispetto a placche metalliche, chiodi che non
verranno mai più tolti, nel caso di mancanza di un lungo segmento osseo.
Passiamo invece ad un esempio di approccio bottom-up, dove invece noi prendiamo un
processo che la natura mette in atto, che è il processo di biomineralizzazione che
la natura attua all'interno del nostro organismo per generare il tessuto osseo.
Il tessuto osseo è, come ho detto, un tipico esempio di biomineralizzazione su un
templante organico, che in questo caso è il collagene. Il collagene fa da base,
mentre si forma il collagene dalla nanofibra alla macrofibra, intessuta a formare
un tessuto, contemporaneamente avviene la deposizione di nanonuclei di
idrossiapatite che danno forza e struttura a questo collagene.
Abbiamo quindi tentato di rifare questo processo in laboratorio, e,
come vedete ci siamo riusciti: abbiamo prodotto un materiale composito,
completamente analogo al tessuto osseo naturale. Avendo raggiunto questo target,
abbiamo pensato che allora potevamo anche riprodurre delle regioni anatomiche
multifunzionali, come per esempio, la regione osteo-cartilaginea, cioè l’articolazione,
dove abbiamo collagene mineralizzato che forma la porzione ossea, la fase minerale
diminuisce gradualmente fino ad arrivare alla cartilagine, che altro non è che
collagene. Quindi, abbiamo pensato, possiamo produrre un materiale a gradiente
composizionale e morfologico, e così abbiamo fatto: abbiamo tentato di riprodurre
l’osso e la cartilagine mineralizzata, e quindi lo strato cartilagineo senza fase
minerale. Questa è, alla vostra destra, vedete il nostro materiale, alla sinistra,
una regione osteo-condrale naturale. Il materiale è stato già sperimentato sull'uomo
ed è in uno studio multicentrico in tutti gli ospedali d’Europa; come vedete,
abbiamo un materiale tristrato, che mima l’osso, la cartilagine mineralizzata e la
cartilagine soprastante. In caso di lesioni non troppo estese, fino a un massimo
di quattro centimetri quadrati, la lesione, sia essa osteoartrite dissecante,
sia essa una lesione dovuta a trauma sportivo, viene eliminata con un intervento,
come vedete in questo filmato, e l'area lesa viene resecata in maniera geometrica,
cosicché il nostro materiale, con delle semplici forbici chirurgiche, può essere
tagliato corrispondentemente, e messo nella lesione.
Le cellule dovute al sanguinamento che passano dal sangue subcondrale
verso lo strato cartilagineo, saranno in grado di differenziarsi in tessuto osseo
nella parte bassa per semplice informazione clinica, e in struttura cartilaginea
nella parte alta. Avremo quindi il completo ripristino della regione osteocondrale e,
nel tempo di circa 3 mesi, la completa ricostruzione, rigenerazione dei tessuti di
osso e cartilagine.
L'istologia dimostra che c'è completa rigenerazione di ossa e cartilagine
Ovviamente, l’impatto che questo materiale può avere è evidente;
qui vedete le protesi tradizionali, la resezione di questo femore,
dentro cui deve entrare un infibulo metallico di circa 20 centimetri,
quindi tutto questo scompare, e abbiamo, come vedete nell'immagine alla vostra destra,
un materiale molto piccolo che, come una mosaico-plastica, va a sostituire la lesione.
E qui vedete l’immagine della lesione ossea e cartilaginea completamente ripristinata
di un paziente curato qui, all’ospedale ortopedico Rizzoli.
Con tutti questi materiali nuovi un gruppo è nato, si è distaccato dal nostro gruppo
di ricerca e ha creato un’impresa hi-tech nel mondo biomediacale;
questa impresa si chiama Finceramica, ha sede a Faenza, ed è diventata leader mondiale
nella riparazione del cranio. Come vi ho spiegato prima,
occorre progettare materiali per la riparazione del cranio in tutti i casi in cui
si ha asportazione dell’opercolo cranico, o per trauma proprio della teca cranica,
e dalla tac del paziente la tac viene inviata ai laboratori,
e sulla tac viene realizzato il pezzo mancante, grazie a un processo di rapid
prototyping che vedete qui nell'immagine. Il materiale viene riconosciuto come proprio,
in quanto riproduce la morfologia e la struttura e la composizione dell’osso umano,
quindi le cellule dalla teca passano all'impianto osseo e lo rigenerano, riformando
osso autologo, cioè l’osso del paziente. Quindi, nel giro di un anno, l’impianto osseo
è scomparso e abbiamo osso paziente, Vedete nell’immagine radiografica la perfetta
continuità tra la protesi e la teca.
L’ultima cosa di cui voglio parlarvi è l’ultima delle innovazioni che abbiamo
realizzato, che è quella di sostituire a piccole concentrazioni di calcio dei nostri
impianti ossei con degli ioni ferro; questo induce una capacità super paramagnetica
nell'impianto osseo che abbiamo progettato. Questo vuol dire che quell'impianto osseo
sarà in grado di rispondere a campi magnetici esterni, anche molto bassi; quindi
quell'impianto funzionerà come una stazione in vivo, controllabile dall’esterno,
quindi io posso aumentare fortemente, attivando l’impianto con dei campi magnetici,
la capacità di rigenerazione del mio impianto: dai 6 mesi posso ridurre probabilmente
a 2 mesi o meno – grazie a un processo di richiamo di attivazione dei fattori
di crescita, dei fattori vascolari. Non solo: abbiamo già verificato,
e lo vedete da questa istologia, che possiamo indurre la formazione di osso lamellare
orientato, e quindi aumentare fortemente le proprietà biomeccaniche di
quel tessuto che andiamo a rigenerare, e da ultimo - forse è un sogno - potremmo
progettare dei fissatori esterni magnetici, e ovviare all'utilizzo di viti,
chiodi che nella prima fase di rigenerazione siamo costretti a mettere per tenere
fermo l’impianto.
Vi lascio, vi ringrazio e vi saluto; vi lascio con questa frase di Seneca che,
pur essendo stata scritta 2000 anni fa, è sicuramente molto attuale
nel mondo della ricerca.
Grazie.